also Thank You Karin my spoken word kind
of stuff has really been the one thing
that these kids no matter where I go
like freak out over so a lot of people
have been telling me to just do a video
for that we've done Instagram YouTube
and all of that and again with the
quality like I'm just you know that's
that's why you're struggling okay you've
you put quality your personal subjective
quality on a pedestal it is such a
cliche reason people struggle you're
gonna have to jump into the pool and
just see what happens in the same way at
a macro level writing the book itself
you've got to basically do the same
thing with social okay there's no piece
of content with bad enough lighting with
with bad enough quality with like
there's no piece of content that's going
to take you down okay so it doesn't
really matter like nobody nobody cares
about your brand positioning in real
life like do you know what I mean like
like you are what you are your brand
says it you're human right you're not a
bottled water whatever you put out is
your actual brand positioning yeah do
you understand yeah so I think you're
you're treating yourself too much like a
product and I think that's inevitably
hurting you okay
which and it's hurting you because of
the authenticity of the content but
because of the utter lack of content
like four to five six times a week on
Instagram is for what your ambition is
and the fact of your target audience at
least in the beginning was younger it's
just not anywhere close to enough okay
and then in terms of like Twitter and
Facebook a snapshot time of day as well
100% okay yeah and Twitter is awesome
because you can just search people's
conversations and engage them in have
you use Twitter search turn on be
searched bullying or other social
justice issues Twitter is a cocktail
party you can interject yourself into
every and any conversation and you
should the others are more content you
know CMS's and you put out content but I
highly recommend that
I was doing research on dinner talent
and like all the ways amazing things
what you guys do
and I was wondering at what point in a
person's career do you suggest like
approaching something like that yeah
because I know it's you know I mean -
yeah to me it's when you can afford to
invest $25,000 a month into you know we
built it because we think it's best in
class and I do think it is and I think
it will inevitably be commodity like I
think more people realize its value and
more people will do it and more people
won't have the overhead costs that I
have so I'm sure will come down in price
over time or finding but like you should
be so for me the way to really win is to
have a pillar right book is a pillar
that's a historic pillar to me a new-age
pillar is either vlog or a podcast and
you should have one or the other period
like to me ironically actually the first
time I'm saying this to me ironically if
you do not have a blog or a podcast
right now you're just leaving an
enormous amount of opportunity to me you
know I guess I'm hedging but like to me
it's you become vulnerable to not being
you to not being relevant like you need
to have both of them one of them or you
need to be an actual celebrity like to
me it's the only thing that equals
having a television show or being an
actor or actress or like it's a pillar
you need a pillar otherwise your social
media content is back dating into
something or it's Rando got it being
like is not relevant well I like it cuz
spoken like it can be it could no I mean
if you put that I think it if people lie
mean when I hear that that's what people
are reacting to like you know maybe you
know either one of two things either you
do a vlog first-person more like KC less
like me and you do a spoken word rap in
it it at some point or I think it's a
great content pillar but you should put
out one every can you put out one every
day yeah that's that's why I like
documenting or
we correct and just documenting yeah the
reason I like documenting or blogging is
you don't have to do anything other than
live your life the reason I like the
podcast is you don't to do anything
other than interviewing somebody so
that's the key the key is to put
yourself in a position where you can
create volume so many more young people
get involved in nonprofits now start
them and then they hit twenty nine
thirty to thirty four and they're like
wait a minute
I'd like to make money wait a minute I'd
like to do this and they have guilt and
they have you know and I always tell
them what you've done more for bullying
already the 99.999% of people oh I guess
my last kind of question to you would be
um two parts in that I was in the
beginning and making mistakes and I you
know would love to get to a place like
where you're at one day and I'm
wondering one how to continue to
monetize something that is not directly
in the business world you know it's like
kind of nonprofit II even though I've
done so the farm trying to find new ways
and then the other aspect just look in
general any advice that you have for
someone in my position trying to climb
that ladder and figure out you
individually yeah I mean thinking of the
reverse engineer what you want so you
have to make a decision between legacy
and financial and that changes all the
time you need financial more in the
beginning or race right the way to
monetize are always from content access
and services or product so the drive
entry ways to make money exist so as you
know like you didn't know this I didn't
know this speaking can be very lucrative
so you could do just fine continuing to
put out content whether in book form
video form blog forum podcast form
Instagram form and then just speak if
you have the ability to speak which
clearly if you're still doing it you do
I mean you can make six figures very
easily speaking which is very good so
should 21 so I think that um you know I
assume I assume with all this are there
opportunities to write another book and
getting a better
you know there's that you look I always
tell people build your brand because
your brand becomes the halo on
everything you get paid more for
speaking you get paid more for books you
know there's opportunities coming to me
that I never could have imagined because
my grand is out there right so I think I
think the podcast a blog public speaking
interviews you know just attention
arbitrage right so my biggest advice is
to deploy patience because you're so
young you've had a lot of happen at it
in a quick period of time you need to
contextualize how much a year-and-a-half
or how much 21 years is in the in the
overall macro of your life and then that
slows you down and you start making
better decisions it's the hardest but
you know I mean you got to decide what
you want do you want to act do you want
to make 40 million dollars do you want
to buy a football teams you want to
start a non-profit do you want to milk
it and then start a family like what do
you want to do or at least what do you
believe you want to do right now and
then all your decisions should be based
on that okay you guys making like a plan
I mean I think everybody does their own
thing I never did I made one kind of
like I want to be a very successful
entrepreneur and I want other people to
like know who I am and that's what I've
done and I want them to know who I am
because I feel like I have something
good to give and I think that builds
real legacy that's why I take random
meetings like this you know you just
provide value you know I read that you
said you know you see call me all you do
to get in one hit and one of you yeah I
mean that's what I think I mean I did
that for years years yeah I never
thought I was fancy I still don't think
I'm fancy you know so I think so yeah
cool you're welcome so much where were
you born
thank you I was born in New York and I
just
is that right yeah padushka ruski but
you understand it at all
tiny tiny bits from was your where your
parents format my you're very pretty
oh my god awesome they make sense
awesome such a pleasure
yeah have a great day sure of course
[Music]